if there is one thing nearly all
language Learners can agree upon it's
this language learning is a slow process
most people learn for months or years
before they see serious results for that
reason many Learners develop an
obsession with speed how can they learn
more in less time what if you could take
any strange of time be it one month one
week or even one day and maximize your
learning so that at the end of that time
you've learned 10 times more than nearly
anyone else could intrigued well watch
this video and I'll show you how hi I'm
lucaran pereiro I'm a Language Coach who
speaks 14 languages and on this channel
I help people learn foreign languages
faster more efficiently and in a fun way
in this video I'll be sharing some tips
for making big progress in a short
amount of time let's start with a little
story which I also talked about in my
video how to learn any language super
fast my three-month plan and which is
again worth mentioning here I started
learning Hungarian in 2016. in late 2022
almost seven years later I had a chance
to visit Budapest again and put some of
my Hungarian skills to the test there I
reconnected with a friend I had made a
few months earlier at the polygon
conference in terezen his name was
Jonathan and he was from Belgium we
spoke a bit Hungarian and when I saw him
interact with native speakers I was
absolutely floored Jonathan's Hungarian
was so natural that I could scarcely
believe he wasn't Hungarian himself
since I had been learning Hungarian for
more than half a decade by then I was
convinced that he had probably been
learning for more than double that if
not more so I asked him how long he had
been learning his answer two years what
two years it seemed impossible naturally
I asked him to explain how he did it
Jonathan then proceeded to tell me about
how when he came to Hungary for the
first time he joined an intensive
one-year language program where he was
required to learn and do everything in
Hungarian from the get-go this gave him
his first initial boost in learning the
language which was Then followed by a
second he started dating a Turkish woman
who he shared no other language with
aside from Hungarian so even though his
girlfriend wasn't a native speaker
Simply Having to constantly speak and
use Hungarian with someone forced
Jonathan to quickly grow his skills and
since he was in Hungary this whole time
they grew even faster as a result so for
two years Jonathan essentially lived and
breathed the Hungarian language without
recourse to French his mother tongue if
I were to summarize the secret to
Jonathan's success was intensity which
is something that is often missing for
most language learning routines when
learning their own target language or
languages most people cannot or won't do
what Jonathan did to learn Hungarian
rather than filling most of their waking
hours with exposure to the language they
instead opt to learn for a small amount
of time each day or less heck even I
recommend to most people to avoid
learning for more than say 30 minutes to
one hour each day and I consider myself
an experienced language why do people
engage in low intensity learning if the
alternative high intensity strategy gets
more impressive results
I think there's one main reason high
intensity learning takes a lot of time a
lot of energy and a lot of effort if you
don't manage these things well you risk
burning yourself out which may decrease
your capacity or desire to learn
languages again in the future lots of
Learners do try the high intensity
learning route only to give it up when
it becomes too much alternatively they
like to learn in a high intensity way
but they do not have the resources to
even attempt it so high intensity
learning can lead to Great results but
it's a costly Endeavor it Demands a lot
from you and if you don't handle it
carefully you can risk burnout
acknowledging the high risk High reward
nature of intense language learning is
probably enough for most people they
either take on the risk or they don't as
simple as that but what if there were a
way to adjust the formula so that we
could get a lot of that reward while
mitigating the potential risk what if we
wanted to transform high intensity
learning into a low-risk higher reward
scenario well we can and I have five
quick tips that can help you do just
that let's get started tip number one
participate in a three-month language
learning challenge even if you'd like to
pull off something like my friend
Jonathan's two-year intensive stint
learning Hungarian and Budapest it's
unlikely you could or would even want to
most of us have things like work family
and well long distances standing in our
way and for many these things cannot be
put aside for two days let alone for two
years the easiest way to learn
intensively then would be to try to
replicate the Intensive experience from
home without having to travel and
without having to spend two years doing
it luckily there are plenty of
opportunities to do this typically in
the form of online language learning
challenges well they all have their own
unique qualities most language
challenges follow the same patterns in
short these challenges require you to
basically do two things one commit to a
specific usually intensive learning goal
and two complete this goal within a
specified period of time the actual
length of the challenge can vary but in
my experience most of the ones you'll
find give you approximately three months
to complete your goal that's how things
work for the two challenges I run in my
own online in school the smart language
learning academy for my beginner and
intermediate language courses during the
challenge we'll share a spreadsheet
where students tick a box every time
they complete their daily activities for
the channel
let me tell you this the joy the
commitment and the results students get
constantly fill me with a lot of Joy
challenges provide a great way to inject
some intensity into your life and
language learning without forcing you to
commit to maintaining that intensity for
a lengthy period of time three months of
intensive learning is certainly a lot
more manageable than two years and you
can always go back to your more laid
back routine once you've finished the
challenge tip number two sign up for a
one month language Camp if you feel like
you're up for something a little more
adventurous than an online learning
challenge there's always the next option
signing up for an in-person intensive
language Camp abroad compared to a three
month challenge this is a bit more
similar to what my friend Jonathan did
to participate in such a camp you would
typically have to actually go abroad and
physically attend lessons in other
activities where use of your target
language is required at a camp like this
you would do your best to learn and use
your target language pretty much all the
time this forces your brain to quickly
adapt to the language and prevents you
from using your target language as a
crutch this can be super stressful but
also super rewarding once you come out
on the other side you could always do a
lengthy program like my friend Jonathan
did for Hungarian but I'm specifically
recommending the short cams and courses
that only last a few weeks to a few
months this will give you a taste of
high intensity language learning but
will require you to sacrifice years of
your life to get it if you're interested
in participating in a program like this
I recommend that you search online and
the country or countries where your
target language is spoken most big
cities will have several such programs
that you can participate in if you're
lucky you might even find similar
programs in your own home country
Americans for example can sign up for
short immersion programs in over a dozen
languages at Middlebury College in
Vermont tip number three take frequent
short trips to the country my next tip
is for those who can travel learn but
cannot commit to doing so for more than
a week or two at a time in cases like
this the best way to maximize your
learning within a short period of time
is actually travel to the country where
your target language is spoken and try
to learn as much as you can while you
are there
as I've mentioned in a specific video I
made about how to maximize your time
while abroad this is not a strategy I
recommend for beginners since there's
simply too much to adjust to if you have
to both learn the language from scratch
and figure out how to survive in a
foreign country that being said Learners
of the intermediate skill level or
Beyond can really boost their skills by
heading abroad and simply use the
language as much as possible the key
here is to spend what little time you
have in the country participating in
learning opportunities that you would
not otherwise be able to for example
you'll probably never have better access
to native speakers or your target
language than when you are traveling
through the places where they live and
where they work so do what you can to
communicate with them as much as you can
ask questions make conversation and
listen to what they have to say simply
being immersed in the same environment
as them will do wonders for your
language skills tip 4 hang out with
native speakers that live in your area
this tip is similar to the last but the
advantage is that you probably will not
have to leave home to do it for this one
my advice is to try to find native
speakers of your target language that
lives somewhere nearby and then actually
hang out with them how easy or how
difficult this is will depend on exactly
where you live but in general finding
local native speakers is becoming easier
and easier to do many popular language
learning apps allow you to search for
and contact native speakers according to
City town or zip code and some even
allow you to find people who are in your
immediate vicinity and willing to chant
if meeting one-on-one is not your thing
then you can also use event platforms
like Meetup to find language themed
events in your area even if you live in
a place where you think native speakers
would be hard to find it's worth a look
there could be a language group nearby
with a native speaker or two once you
find a native speaker to chat with the
next thing to do is simply spend time
with them if you're both open to it
there's no reason why you could not do a
regular one-on-one language exchange or
even hang out with them more casually
whenever you do spend time with a native
speaker just remember that you have a
great opportunity to learn a lot in a
short period of time so be curious ask
questions and above all try to have a
good time even if something that may
appear to others like a casual hangout
can actually be an intensive language
learning activity some of my periods of
fastest language learning progress have
come from meeting Natives and showing
them around my hometown so it's
something I highly recommend tip number
five if you can go on dates with native
speakers
this last tip is quite powerful but not
something that everyone can do date or
marry a native speaker of your target
language being in a relationship with a
native speaker is like my last tip but
turned up to 11. hanging out with a
native speaker for a few hours at a time
can do wonders for your language
learning but actually living and
building a life with a native speaker
can push your skills to a level that
would be nearly impossible to reach
otherwise
when you are in a relationship with
another person you are a nearly constant
contact with them and for the
relationship to succeed you need to be
able to communicate your needs and wants
at a high level and do so consistently
this is a toll order for two people that
speak the same language natively so to
put it off when they're the native
speaker and you're the non-native
speaker is a huge task that will require
a Herculean effort on your part and a
similar amount of patience from your
partner if you can pull it off though
the results will be incredible I've had
this experience several times myself
most notably when I was living and
studying in France in my late 20s and
early 30s I had a French girl for
another time and the amount of French
that I learned from her was absolutely
staggering there was an added benefit
too spending time with her also
necessitating spending lots of time with
her friends and relatives so I learned a
lot about the language from them as well
so if you're single and have an
opportunity to go on dates with a native
I'd say give it a try of course I don't
think you should ever date someone just
because they speak your target language
natively but if you two have a real
spark then you'll have an intensive
language learning experience like no
other all right those are my tips for
maximizing your language learning over a
short period of time following these
tips it will allow you to extract the
most language learning value from any
short Sprint be it a few hours a few
days a few weeks or a few months
[Music]
let's quickly review the tips one
participate in a three-month language
learning challenge two sign up for a one
month language camp
three take frequent short trips to the
country
four hang out with native speakers that
live in your area
five if you can go on dates with native
speakers if you'd like to try intensive
language learning for yourself then I
recommend signing up for one of the
courses in my become a master language
learner series I've got one course for
beginners and another one for
intermediate Learners and if you sign up
for those then you'll be able to join
intensive three-month language learning
challenges which we do several times a
year for each course if you're
interested then look down in the
description box for more information
thanks for watching and as always happy
language learning